[Music]
[Applause]
hi everyone
Happy Easter and welcome to the table
we are live my name is Karen and I'm so
glad you were with us today you know
this isn't just our first online only
Easter service this is our very first
Easter service ever here at the table so
you were a part of history this evening
and although this service is different
than we had originally envisioned a few
months ago it's been planned with the
same amount of love and inclusivity and
thoughtfulness a little bit of eclectic
thrown in there for good measure and
just want you to feel welcome here and
feel a part of our family if you're
visiting with us for the first time a
special welcome to you we want you to
just feel honored and celebrated and
bring all that you are to the table so
let's kick it off with a couple of
announcements just as people are
starting to join us and hop online with
us today did you notice the pun hop
online it's Easter so first announcement
you are watching us online right
Facebook and YouTube some of you have
been following us on Instagram and we
just want to share the love so make sure
you're liking us following us on
Facebook and Instagram and on Facebook
especially there's a little button that
says follow if you click on that that
will make sure that you see our
information throughout the week and
that's what we want to do we want to
connect with you throughout the week and
one of the highlights for me during this
quarantine time has been our daily
voices from the table videos just people
from our community sharing things that
are encouraging and uplifting to them
during this pandemic so please make sure
you're following us online and secondly
we have our meetups and meetups at the
table are our small groups and the good
news is they're more accessible than
ever right now because
they're all happening online I'd love
for you to be a part of them we have a
new one that has just started up and
some others that would love to have you
so to get connected with those you can
send us a message through Facebook or
Instagram or you can email me directly
Karen kar en at the table TX org so how
about bad before we get started let's
begin with some prayer so bow your head
with me
close your eyes take a deep breath God
here we are
an Easter Sunday like no other a day
that's usually marked with large
gatherings bustling church buildings and
busy streets there's not much that feels
normal right now but they McGann not
much was normal about that first Easter
over 2,000 years ago I'm reminded that
you don't lead us into normal you lead
us into new I'm reminded that death and
suffering do not have the final word
love does you Becca nuts through
darkness and disorientation and
disbelief towards a new day a better day
a resurrection day not just for a chosen
for you but for all of humanity god help
us to Center on you and place our hope
in you even as we try to cling to our
versions of normal help us to see your
wonder as you make all things new and to
trust you in the process thank you for
being with us every step of the way and
for being our living hope we pray all of
this together in Jesus name Amen
being Easter is all about the chocolate
bunnies
what does Easter mean to you all about
resurrection it means renewal and
eternal life jesus's life has always
been a life that is to be an example to
us and I think that his example is that
we are called to live a life of
sacrifice to all those around us even if
it means unto death it bodies what I
feel like is the hinge of the gospel
which is come and lay down your life and
find that you can truly live we tried to
kill God we hang him on the tree in the
ground he forgave us and he got back up
I guess the main thing that Easter means
to me it represents to me is hope and
hope is everything all the times I've
needed help and then he still saw me and
gave his life for me because we belong
to him and knowing that he our Lord our
Savior our King conquered the grave
tells me that he's got me my life and
all of my challenges well in that for me
has been the secret to freedom is the
war I'm able to let go and give myself
away give my life away and stop
protecting stop striving I find life the
end yeah that's been everything ether me
needs hope
more specifically hope for a new life it
was two years ago a week before ether
that I completely given up in my life I
suffer from severe depression and mental
on this my entire life I felt in doing
my soul that my life was ultimately
hopeless that there was no chance he'll
it's gonna turn out okay as long as I
was the one living in I truly believe
that everyone I knew including myself we
better off if I were dead so I plan to
end my life
but as I planned so did God over three
days taught me just how far you'd
already gone to show me this love in the
cross well I'm sitting here two years
later to tell you that Jesus is still
alive still doing miracles now I'm not
saying I'm perfect or have a perfect
life it's far from it but what I can say
there's no matter their struggles our
darkness my face my life I have hope
hope of Christ hope of new life I know
that's my story not everyone is the same
but I also know we all face struggles in
the inner darkness that doesn't have
that in there those things don't get to
define us anymore we have hope because
we were still there is a God who has
already won in the battle no matter what
you're facing you are not alone whether
it's depression anxiety or whatever you
have hope because the same Jesus who
went to the cross and conquered death
loves you beyond comprehension and is on
your side
[Music]
Wow I'm so grateful that Darryl shares
his story with us it's such a beautiful
reminder to me that things are often
darkest right before the dawn and it's
in our darkness in our brokenness that I
find Jesus and the light of Resurrection
breaking through and available to us
we're gonna sing a song together now I
feel like a minute it's called living
hope and it's a song that Darrell
introduced me to it was one that was
really meaningful to him during his
journey coming out of that depression
and suicidal tendencies and I hope that
today it will be meaningful for us as a
community just as a reminder of that
resurrection life of that hoop and light
that we find in Jesus and in the message
of Easter today
[Music]
I
the declare the grave there's no claim
[Music]
[Applause]
this is from first Peter and it says
praise be to God
a father of our Lord Jesus in His great
mercy he has given us new birth into a
Living Hope through the resurrection of
Jesus Christ from the dead and into an
inheritance that will never perish spoil
or fade thanks Mindy
[Music]
the world
father God thank you for this time
together we thank you for resurrection
life and I pray that today as we reflect
on your son Jesus that we we we would be
renewed father and we would feel that
hope that joy that comes with knowing
you've got it's in your name I pray amen
amen
friends of the table he is risen
it's so so good to be with you a huge
thank you to Gary and Mindy Jacobs
working behind the scenes to do all of
our tech and Ryan Bay Ron has put
together that video and they'll be one
later and yeah just really really
grateful and Karen who's doing our
welcome and everything so it's yeah it's
just so so good to be with you all I say
it every week I wish I could just hug
your beautiful faces is that possible to
think of I don't know but yeah I do I
miss y'all but it's so good to be
together my heart he's so cool I can see
the comments on the side and just like
interact a little bit and connect is
just so so good so thank you for being
with us I know there's a few folks who
are this is the first time joining us
so welcome really really glad to have
you and yeah so let's jump right in so
the title of my message this Easter
Sunday as Karen mentioned the first
table Easter Sunday is prepare to be
surprised
prepare to be surprised and I'd like to
begin with a few different readings from
the Gospels this first one is gonna be
from John chapter 20 so for those who
learned of the Bible there's four
Gospels Matthew Mark Luke John we're
gonna be reading from just three of them
so first John 20 verses 1:32 says early
on the first day of the week while it
was still dark Mary Magdalene went to
the tomb and saw that the stone had been
removed from the entrance so she came
running to Simon Peter and the other
disciple the one Jesus loved and said
they have taken the Lord out of the tomb
and we don't know where they have put
him the next text this is um the Gospel
of Luke chapter 24 verses 9 through 11
when they came back from the tomb they
told all of these things to the eleven
and to all the others it was Mary
Magdalene Joanna Mary the mother of
James and the others with them who told
this to the apostles but they did not
believe the women because their words
seemed to them like nonsense and then
one final passage this is Matthew
chapter 28 verses 1617 it's short and
sweet then the eleven disciples went to
Galilee to the mountain where Jesus had
told them to go and when they saw him
they worshiped him but some doubted
and I love I mean I love all those
but that last this last passage from
Matthew in particular because notice
these are not people here in second hand
about the Risen Jesus and then being you
know a little bit skeptical they are
actually seeing the Risen Jesus they're
like no it can't be and in other words
what strikes us about these gospel
passages are not the people's great
faith correct I mean here's what you
don't hear in the accounts above we just
read we done here and they came to the
empty tomb and they said well well there
you have it just like he said I
shouldn't have doubted here I've been
twisting myself up into emotional knots
for the last three days all for nothing
He is risen no no instead they are
hesitant and downright a skeptical and
here's the truth I - and the skeptic now
it's partly personality but it's also
partly due to the atmosphere of the
culture I have spent my life within I am
a child of the west of Western culture
and specifically of something that
happened a few hundred years ago but we
continue to feel its ripple effects
called the Western enlightenment now by
enlightenment I don't mean the eastern
concept of you know becoming the
enlightened spiritual person achieving
union with God or something I mean the
Western enlightenment tradition of
rationalism not faith scientism not
spirituality individualism not tradition
I'm talking about the Enlightenment that
wanted to you might say dripped the acid
of reason
to everything yes I am a child of the
Western enlightenment I mean if you say
something to me anything to me on any
topic I'm skeptical
like I'm skeptical before you've even
finished speaking I'm like has that
article been fact checked was that was
that scientific study a a double-blind
placebo test because that's all I trust
I am a child of the Enlightenment and on
the one hand I'm grateful for that
for that inheritance because I think
good clear thinking is important and yet
it is vulnerable you see having been
born in the second half of the 20th
century I'm also a child of what is
known as the post enlightenment or the
post modern that means after the modern
which means I'm so skeptical I'm even
skeptical of my skepticism you see you
start off by perhaps becoming skeptical
of either your or others you know
religious beliefs you know all the
assumptions you have that God is there
that Jesus was who he said he was and
you know you become an Enlightenment
person you believe in your capacity for
you know objectivity and reason and
clear thinking and you know you've left
behind
foolish wishful thinking and all that
and for a time you are confident you're
confident in in this newfound capacity
to find the truth and even to be good
without God and religion and stuff and
such but then you keep studying and
suddenly maybe after reading Nietzsche
he will ruin the most secular among us
you realize that it was actually faith
faith in God it was it was even a faith
in Christian theology which was
grounding which was giving a firm
foundation
to your entire search for what is good
and what is true in the first place and
suddenly you understand that once you
let go of God then what you don't have
is capital T truth right but simply an
unending multiplicity of lowercase T
truths all competing and jostling for
supremacy you realize there is no grand
story to make sense of the world not
even scientism there's just a bunch of
foolish opinions masquerading as the
truth and honestly the whole search for
truths it's sort of sort of pointless
because in the end you know what people
you know people call the truth but it's
just called popularity right it's
whatever's trendy and popular at that
time or whatever had the most power in
dollars behind it that's all there is
your foolish truth and along with truth
eventually may not realize it at first
but eventually goes goodness and ethics
I mean of course you think people ought
to be nice but really I mean that's just
your opinion I mean who are you to say
what is good for anyone else I mean
you're the true skeptic you know you're
skeptical of what others believe you're
skeptical of what you believe it's just
question marks all the way down and you
may not know it but there is a concept
for the creeping sensation that you're
experiencing and it's one of the great
problems of our time by great I don't
mean awesome
I mean tremendously influential it's one
of the tremendous problems of our time
and it's the word nihilism nihilism
means the rejection of belief in any and
all aspects of human life whether you're
talking religious philosophical moral
political it's it's an extreme sort of
skepticism about what everything
and if the you might call the the
Achilles heel
you know the weakness of of Christianity
is doubt you know the thought maybe I'm
wrong well then the Achilles heel of a
postmodern I'm so skeptical I'm even
skeptical of my skepticism is nihilism
it's sort of like at first you know when
you're questioning and maybe even sort
of rejecting religious beliefs it feels
sort of meaningful beautiful good true
important until you realize that you've
lost the very basis of truth of beauty
of goodness of meaningfulness of
importance at all yes today we've all
got more than a little of the skeptic in
us a few weeks ago I had a remarkable
conversation with a friend and he's
someone he left the Christian faith of
his childhood kind of behind many years
ago and he knows about my own journey
um how about 10 years ago or so I nearly
lost my own Christian faith as well you
could probably pick up on that from the
first part of this message uh but then
he also knows that I came back you know
to faith to Christian faith and he asked
me he said how how did you do it oh he
said I just I don't I don't understand
man like I just I mean I'm not I'm not
upsetting you I just I don't understand
how you can just leave and it was
interesting because I was sitting there
and I don't remember if I actually said
this out loud but I remember thinking I
don't understand how you cannot believe
because I can't speak for everyone but
for all of the skeptic in me I am at the
same time a believer down to my toes I
mean if I believe in anything
I believe that God
is love and I don't just mean love in
the abstract as some sort of sentimental
sweetness no I mean the kind of
beautiful challenging selfless love that
Jesus displayed if I believe anything
it's that we should look out for each
other especially the poor the elderly
the weaker ones among us if I believe
anything I believe that no matter how
far gone someone is no matter how
reprehensible or horrible the deed they
have done redemption can be had for them
if I believe anything I believe that no
matter what we may be facing whether a
pandemic or sickness or global warming
or racism or nuclear weapons or
alcoholism molestation abuse drug
addiction divorce depression I believe
that nothing no nothing can ever
separate us from the love of God if I
believe anything
I believe that when Jesus said I tell
you love your enemies pray for those who
persecute you that when he died on the
cross and said Father forgive them they
do not know what they are doing I
believe that was not weakness that was
what true strength looks like it takes
strength to love it takes strength to
forgive it takes spiritual power to pray
and show compassion to people who
despise you and if I believe anything I
believe that this world is not an
accident and that goodness and morality
the way we live and act and treat one
another now that it echoes for eternity
and if I believe anything when I look at
a cold dead body I believe that is not
the end for them
I believe that death does not get the
final word and if I believe in all those
things then guess what else I believe in
resurrection and I don't mean
resurrection as some sort of a metaphor
for the timeless principle of death and
rebirth that's not Christianity I mean
the actual resurrection of Jesus from
the dead in the trust right because
that's what it is it's not certainty the
trust that what God has done for Jesus
he will one day do for you and me and
all of creation because if Jesus is not
resurrected then a a creeping nihilism
really just might be the truest thing
about the world but because he is
resurrected it means that God really is
loved that there really is hope and that
no matter what you are facing today
nothing nothing can ever separate you
from the love of God and so on this
Easter Sunday
I have no tips and tricks for your life
I have no take-home points or action
items for you to implement I simply want
to name this Jesus is risen and that
surprising truth changes everything we
go ahead and bow your head with me um
perhaps you've found yourself in a place
of intense skepticism and doubt or maybe
as the years have passed you might have
simply just kind of drifted
from really believing in then living as
though you believe and if that's you
then I want to invite you to pray this
prayer Lord Jesus I trust that your
resurrection is true I trust that you
are present to me now forgive my sins my
doubts my pride my ego got me nothing in
my life ever be the same
amen if you prayed that prayer I want to
encourage you to reach out and let us
know so that we can make sure that you
have the support and the encouragement
that you need for your journey so you
can kick me or the table a message on
Facebook or email me Brett at the table
TX org that's BR e TT our web address
and I'd love to be in touch with you so
I love you all
celebrate be glad Happy Easter
[Music]
me too
[Applause]
[Music]
Jesus thank you for the reminder of a
resurrection thank you that it's
available to us today for each one of us
resurrection can still happen
help us to engage that hope in our own
lives help us to put it into practice in
our relationships and in our world God
we love you Jesus and we're so grateful
for the gift of hope and new life well
some of you may have been catching the
voices of the table videos that we've
been doing now he's been helping with
that each day if you haven't tuned in to
our table Facebook Instagram but one of
the videos that you may have seen was
Carter Livingston sharing a recording
that he did a black bird by the Beatles
and as soon as he shared it I couldn't
help but thinking of Resurrection and
Easter and the message that we celebrate
on this weekend and it just reminded me
of how hope finds us in our brokenness
in our darkness in our doubt hope and
light break through resurrection comes
and so um we wanted to take a little bit
of time during the service even though
social distancing has kept us from being
able to collaborate very much in our
worship services we're unfortunately not
able to play at the same time in
different locations however there have
been several people from our team who
put in some time and creativity to bring
us a
video of a compilation of Blackbird
where even in our social distancing we
are still coming together and
celebrating Easter as a community so I
hope that you guys enjoy this rendition
[Music]
blackbird singing in the dead of night
take these broken wings and learn to fly
all your you were only waiting for its
moment to be free you're only waiting
[Music]
hmm so good we are so glad that you
joined us today I hope that this time
has been a blessing to you and a
reminder that you are not alone we're
gonna keep the livestream rolling for a
few more minutes so please take a moment
to chime in and let us know that you
were here we want every voiced account
at the table and in the meantime I'll
leave you with this benediction may the
reminder of resurrected life bring
renewed hope to your soul may the
continued story after earthly death turn
your eyes to the promises of heaven may
the journey from the cross to the empty
tomb help you to trust God and persevere
through your darkest nights and may
Christ's unending love anchoring hope
and redeeming Grace reign in your heart
forever your loved be blessed
Happy Easter